Hello, everyone. All right. Okay. How is everyone doing today?
Just want to make sure I've got everybody added in. Perfect. I think we are good for now.
All right. I'm going to share the screen here. Okay. Hopefully everybody can see that. Happy Monday.
Here we are once again. Last Monday in September. Oh my gosh. I just can't believe how fast time flies.
But anyways, looking forward to some nice sunny October days and the leaves changing. They're starting
to change here. So all is good. I love fall. Okay. So we'll get right in. We had a few questions that
came in. First, we have just a little announcement. Nothing. Nothing major. Other than we have a
new phone number for the store. So you now can call the store directly. So if you have a question
about an order, if you want to add something to an order, you placed, if you forgot something,
or you need to place your order over the phones for whatever reason. Just anything regarding
supplements or the store if you have a question. So we have a new store number. So you can make a note
of that there. 6512994867. And I think that's also, you know, it's on our voicemails. And I'm not
exactly sure where it is on the website yet. But we have that new store phone number. So that will be
helpful. That will ease up on a lot of the phone calls coming into, you know, marine and the people
who are answering the phones. So it kind of separates the store from the clinic. And so we can kind
of streamline those calls. So they are more readily addressed. Okay. And then we have a shipping
email address. We've always had a shipping email address. But I just don't know if people are aware.
So we do have the shipping email address. And so again, if you wanted to reach out to the
shipping department through the email address, you certainly can do that. So make a note of those.
Okay. And the first question that came in is regarding an air purifier. And if we can recommend
a one for use in a bedroom, so a smaller space. And I'm not super immersed in all of the options as
far as an air purifier. But I do know, you know, I follow a lot of the natural wellness people on
different, you know, social media platforms. I guess really just one. I'm only on Instagram. I'm
not on Facebook. But anyways, the air doctor is one of the ones that I see them talk about a lot that
uses a HEPA filter. So really it comes down to the quality of the filter. And the HEPA filter is
great. I'm just checking in. Okay. Somebody had a question. I'll address that in a moment here.
It's air purifier. So the air doctor is a good one. So you can kind of look that up and do a
little bit of research on that. The other one that I have been really curious about is called the
Molecule M-O-L-E-K-U-L-E. So that uses a pretty advanced or technology that I hadn't
haven't really seen before. It's called PICO Technology P-E-C-O. And again, I don't know a ton
about this, but I have been intrigued and kind of looked at their devices and you know thought
about purchasing one. They are a little more spendy. But they do use a filter obviously. The filter
that they have, it blocks the large particles. And then on the very inside, there is a light
technology that is used to really destroy the smaller things within the air. All of those smaller
pollutants that the filter traps the larger particles and then the light is literally destroying
the smaller particles with light technology. So I thought that was interesting. And you know, of course,
with us using the RIFE machine, light technology, frequency generators to attack, you know,
cancer cells and in different viruses and bacteria, I thought the Molecule is pretty interesting
because they're using light technology as well. And I know that they're filters. So the technology is
within the filter. And so anytime there is an advance in their technology, when you reorder a
replacement filter, you're getting the most current and updated technology within that filter. So
that's kind of cool as well. So they're big on research and development and they do update their filters
and better their filters. And so the filters are probably more expensive, I would imagine as well.
So, but check that one out. So those are the two that I know a little bit about time. So you can check
those out. Next question has to do with her husband is dealing with hand and foot syndrome from chemo.
His feet are peeling quite a bit. What can be done to help with this? So I have this goofy little
picture up here because I've told a few patients and it's funny because I used to do this back
back in the day when I was young to keep my hands moisturized at night. I put lotion on and then I
wear gloves to bed at night to sleep and wake up with soft, moisturized hands. And so when this
question came in, I thought of that. And this is just like a screen capture from Amazon. I was just
thinking, I don't even know what these are called, but I just searched for moisturizing gloves
and socks. So certainly you can lather up with a non toxic moisturizer, put these on your hands and
feet at night to really just kind of help reduce that peeling. So ultimately with chemo, this is
a common side effect as you get just really sore blistering kind of peeling hands and feet. And it's
part of an inflammatory, you know, the inflammatory response. So anything anti inflammatory that you
can take internally, something like clear and flam, you know, would be really good to help just
reduce inflammation. Make sure you're following the chemo protocol. I don't know if this person is on
the chemo protocol. We've talked quite a bit about the chemo protocol and all of the different things
that you can do to help protect your healthy cells. You know, you want to do some fasting prior to chemo
administration wait then 24 or excuse me 48 hours from the administration of chemo and 48 hours
after that to do any real real detoxing because we want the chemo to work has its mask maximum effect on
those cancer cells within that 48 hours hours. And then after that, we want to just rapidly try to pull
that chemotherapy out of the body because that's when it starts attacking the healthy cells. So if you
don't have a copy of the chemo protocol or you're not familiar, not following that reach out and we
can get that in get that to the chemo protocol. So I would suggest really following that there's some
supplements that can be helpful as well. So follow the chemo protocol. You certainly could try, you know,
a safe lotion, you know, using shea butter. I would maybe just try shea butter at first. You could
add some essential oils like lavender, which is really calming. You can and then put the gloves on
and the socks on at night and see if that helps really amp up the detoxing after chemotherapy.
I'm not sure if you're able to do the foot bath. I imagine with kind of maybe peeling, blistering,
skin on the feet, it might be painful to do a foot bath, but you could use any of the rife programs for
detoxing the bulb programs for detoxing. So anything with the liver support kidney function, any of those
general detoxing programs, you can run those instead of the foot bath, if the foot bath is too painful.
So try those things and I don't know if they'll help for sure, but you certainly can try them.
Yes, that sounds very uncomfortable and painful. All right, the next question. Thank you for all
of the help we've gotten from your clinic. We just got our genetic review back and a couple more
supplements, including curcumin. We're suggested we are already spending about $700 a month for supplements.
These would bring it to about $850. Could I buy bulk turmeric with 80 or excuse me, 95% curcumin
oids instead instead and use it with a fat for bioavailability? I think the curcumin is really important.
And the answer is yes. So yes, we understand that supplements can be can be spending and then you
know, we're asking you to add a few more based on the genetic information. Remember, those are just
suggestions. Nobody has to take our supplement recommendations. But if you're trying to, of course,
adhere to our recommendations, then you can sort of supplements from other places. You don't have to
buy them from us. And if you have an option or a place where you can buy bulk turmeric high quality,
then that is great. You can use that. You can take it with a fat, like you said, for bioavailability.
That would be great. Yeah. So I would encourage you to do that. You might have to take more. I don't
know exactly what you're buying. You might have to take more to kind of get it to a higher level. I'm not
sure, but maybe you could take it, you know, three times a day. If it's a powder that you're you're literally
mixing with a fat, you know, like coconut oil, then you might have to do it, you know, multiple times
throughout the day to kind of get to that same dose. But you certainly could play with that. And if
that is more economical, and that is absolutely fine. All right. The next question. I just read an
article from a medical journal about tumors using dead cancer cells to form new tumors. The article
said low dose aspirin can produce resilience, which stimulate macrophages to clean up the cell
garbage. Is this something all cancer patients should be using to help clean up cancer cell garbage?
So the answer is no, not necessarily. Certainly anybody can, you know, try any therapy that they
would like to see if it can help, but just because it might be good for one person doesn't necessarily
mean it is going to help everyone. So, so we don't make those kind of general
recommendations for everyone. We really are testing. And, you know, we're not testing on aspirin.
We're testing on natural supplements. So we can't really make a suggestion for you to take this
aspirin therapy. You do need to be careful with aspirin because it can be a blood thinner,
so it can cause bruising and some capillary fragility. So you need to be careful with that. Just be
cautious. You know, and, but do know that there are other ways to help clean up cellular debris
and pathogens. And we talk about this in the genetic review. So I pulled this from the genetic tab on
the membership site, this image here. And these are some of the genes that we look at that help you
get to this place where we're doing that cellular cleanup and repair. So in today's world,
we're kind of constantly stimulating something called mTOR. If you're looking at this graphic,
then all of these little things in yellow that are kind of on the outer edges, these are all stimulating
mTOR. And, and all of these things are, you know, things that we're exposed to on a daily basis.
We've got food, you know, available to us on every corner, you know, we're never in a position where
we don't have access to foods. So we're eating more, a lot more frequently than our ancestors did.
We're not getting in a state where we're really fasting or hungry. So fasting is one of the best ways
to clean up cellular debris and just to allow your body to get into this state called a topogy.
So mTOR and a topogy are kind of opposite ends of a teeter totter. They cannot both be active at
the same time. And we seem to be in this environment where we're constantly having a lot of things that
are stimulating mTOR and not so many things that are promoting a topogy. And with all of our cancer
patients, we really want to shift this. So we are promoting a topogy in that cellular repair and
clean up of waste. So the best ways to do that, as I mentioned, are by doing some fasting. So
there's information in your binders about time restricted eating. If we've gone through your genetics,
we may have advised you to start implementing some time restricted eating based on some of these genes
here. So all genes are listed kind of in this kind of peachy color here. So these are genes that
stimulate a topogy. And if you have variants here, then we need to implement some things to help
your body get into this phase of a topogy because variants can hinder that. And here's other genes here
that play a role. So if we have issues on our gene related to EMF, we can be stimulating mTOR.
So we need to do things to protect our body from EMF. If we're eating high sugar, we're stimulating
mTOR. Iron enriched foods, methyl-methylated B vitamins, MSG, monosodium glutamate, bone
broth. So this is one of the reasons why we're telling you to avoid bone broth is because bone broth
can stimulate mTOR, pesticides, and five methyl tetrahedral folate supplementation. So all of these
things can stimulate mTOR. So we want to minimize these things and we want to promote a topogy. So
these are things that promote a topogy. So fasting, resveratrol, tumoric, and then supporting your
tumor suppressor genes all helps you promote a topogy. So you can also look for different
rife programs, DNA repair, all of these things can help promote a topogy. So while we can't tell you
that you should start this aspirin therapy, you certainly can decide on your own if you
would like to do that. Do that with caution, just because of the things that we mentioned, the
blood thinning, but do know that there's other ways to stimulate autophagy and cellular cleanup.
So take a look at those. All right, next question. I ended up with COVID after my pneumonia. Oh gosh,
darn it. I have lost some taste and all of my smell. Do you have any ideas to help get that back
faster? So yes, we do have some ideas to help get that back faster. So when we're talking about
taste and smell, you know, they're really closely intertwined in the brain, which is why when you lose
one or one senses dull, they both kind of are. So when you're sick in general, you know, or you have
a stuffed up nose and you can't smell things, you know, it minimizes your taste. And the tongue,
you know, really senses the main things as far as taste. So, you know, sweet, sour, bitter,
those types of things, but smell is really what creates the nuances as far as taste. So it really
gives us the ability to sense the flavor of something. So they really are closely related. They
work hand in hand together. And with COVID, obviously, yes, that is a very common common side
effect of COVID is the loss of taste and smell. So there are some things you can do. My son had COVID
way, way back in the early, early, early days. And he was in Arizona at the time. And when he came home,
you know, he was about three months later where he actually moved back home. And he's still
struggling with taste and smell. And so I did a tiny bit of research on it. And from home, you know,
we just did some therapy using essential oils and the rife machine. So I read an article that stated
that rose eucalyptus clove and lemon were essential oils that all affect different areas of the
old factory nerve. We didn't have rose. And so I think I just we just used a floral. So, you know,
kind of do the best you can with the essential oils, but maybe just choose four essential oils that
you have. And then we use the rife machine. And we used some nerve programs on the rife machine. So
while he was running the nerve programs on the rife machine, I was having them smell the essential
oils. So just one at a time, taking one for, you know, 15, 20 seconds. And then grabbing the other
one and just kind of rotating through those throughout the length of whatever nerve program we were
running. And I put these up here on the bottom of the screen because you can do a search. If you're
in the rife software, you've clicked on the open program button. And obviously that's where you'll
find your folder that we've created for you. But then there's, you know, the list of all the general
programs that you can scroll through on the right side. But on the left side, there's this little search bar
or search function where you can type in keywords and search for different right programs
that have that word in it. So I know it's tiny print, but I typed in nerve here. So you have to have
the name highlighted right here, this little button. And then you type in whatever term or word you're
searching for. So you type it in and then you actually have to physically go over and hit the search
button over here. So you do that. And then it will come up with a list of programs if there are any
that have that word in it. So you might need to change, you know, I have nerve here. There might be
program that have nerves plural, you know, so you might need to change up the keyword a little bit to
find some good programs. But so then it brings up all of the lists, the list of programs that have
the word nerve or nerves in it. And you can actually run a program directly from here. You can double
click on it, but it gives you an idea of where to look for things or the title. So you can look through
that alphabetical list and find programs to run. So if I were doing this again, you know, I would just do
the same thing because my son said it really did help him. He said he probably went from feeling like he
had 50% of taste and smell to about 80% just after a few sessions of this. And then, you know, it takes
a while to get it to get it back. It does come back. But I certainly would try doing this again.
Just run these nerve programs and get some essential oils and just keep smelling them even if you
can't or breathing them in through your nose, even if you can't technically smell them. But just
continue to deep breath through the nose and eventually the nerves will heal and the cells around
those nerves. So I read another article a few months back saying that it's not necessarily the nerve,
that's damaged, the olfactory nerve. But they think it might be the olfactory cells that are around
the nerve. But in either case, you know, doing these things can help repair nerves and cells in that area
to help regain taste and smell. So hopefully that helps. And then the second part of the question is
still struggling to gain weight. I'm not losing right now, but cannot seem to gain. I've added two
grains a day and started counting calories to make sure I'm getting enough. Any other ideas than what
we have talked about. Thank you. So I'm glad to hear that you're not losing weight. So you've been
sick. So pneumonia, COVID. So you haven't lost any weight. So that is a win because a lot of times
during these any sicknesses, we really lose the appetite, we lose weight. So I'm glad you're not
haven't lost. But yes, it can be a struggle to regain. So absolutely good that you're adding
grains to grains a day. I would say maybe try to increase your serving size of those grains,
get a rotation of grains. So a variety of grains certainly getting calorie dense foods in. So avocado, sweet
potato, coconut oil, nuts and seeds. And we've probably talked about all of these things. But I would
just encourage you to keep trying to snacking on those things, adding adding nuts and oils to any
smoothies or any meals that you're preparing to just add some calories into each meal. And I do have
a little one sheet on different tips to try and regain some healthy weight. So if anybody wants
that, just reach out to me. But it's ultimately all these things that I'm mentioning now. So just keep
at it. The grains are the best. And certainly you could add protein powder, add an extra scoop of
protein powder to your smoothies, something like that. And getting healthy fats in and calorie
dense foods. And it will come. Hopefully it will come. Okay, next question. Does my right
machine need to be adjusted to be more effective after receiving all of the genetic info? So that's
a really good question. And it's a common question. And the answer is no, it does not. So the
right machine is independent from your genetic results. The right is programmed for your specific type
of cancer in any frequencies that Dr. Conner's beliefs are going to be helpful for you given your
specific diagnosis. So that's how the right machine is programmed. So the genetics does not change
the right programming. The genetics are just obviously giving us information about you as an
individual and how your body works and how we can better support your body. So it functions
optimally at a higher level. So we can get a little more into the nitty gritty as far as specific
nutrient specific diet dietary changes or some specific lifestyle things to help optimize detox pathways
to maximize just getting nutrition out of the foods that you're eating. All of these things that are
related to specific genetic pathways. So that is what we're looking at the genetic information for.
So it doesn't change the right machine or the right programming. That's a really good question.
Okay, next question. I talked with you about the Berber Clear or Berberine Synergy upsetting my
stomach and the suggestion was to try it at different times. I have tried it before I eat after I eat
during the meal. It fills up my stomach a lot of the time and makes me feel like vomiting or vomiting
when I have eaten. I am wondering if I need to take it. It has been reduced from five when I started.
So this is another great great question that I thought would be beneficial for everyone to hear
because again, supplements are recommendations. So everybody has a different reaction to supplements and
you know things can change too where you started out taking something and you were fine and maybe
you've kind of built up a tolerance to something and it's now affecting you differently. So
you can change your supplements if you are experiencing a symptom that is not desirable. So vomiting
and not feeling well, feeling sick to your stomach is absolutely undesirable and you know you feel
I feel for you and you know any type of symptoms that you're experiencing. So you do not have to
take it. You can try different things. You could try to even lowering the dose even more. You could
try taking it every other day. You could try taking one capsule every other day, one capsule you know
just two days a week and see if that makes a difference. Sometimes you just need to lower the dose
even more or sometimes you can just take a break from a supplement. You know just take two weeks off
and see how you feel and then you know we can maybe reintroduce it again but starting at a low dose
again and if you automatically when upon reintroduction feel that same way again then you know maybe
we just need to pause on that supplement a little bit longer. So you can take the liberty of playing
with that but I'm glad you know you reached out because just let us know because then we can make a note
in our system if you are minimizing something or if you're having a specific reaction to a supplement
we do make note of that so we have that in our record so so just play with it but we certainly can
take a pause on that. All right any thought on the immunotherapy or are there things to look out for?
So yes there are so obviously immunotherapy we can't make a recommendation two or four
four or against it because it is medical conventional therapy but there are some things to be careful
of and just to be aware of so ultimately when you're taking immunotherapy you are hyper firing the
TH1 branch of the immune system so that is the non-specific killer response branch of the immune
system and this can cause some issues you know maybe not with everybody but some with some people
there can be some side effects of that it can because you're getting this super hyped up response in
the killer response it can start to attack your healthy tissue. The goal is obviously for it to attack
the cancer cells the immune system to really attack the cancer cells but it can start attacking the
body can start attacking itself in the healthy tissue so it can cause autoimmune conditions and
some inflammatory conditions so you just have to be very careful and really pay attention to your
body and how you're feeling on it you know work with your doctor on that and you know we do have a
protocol if somebody does begin immunotherapy and you know it's really just a kind of help
prevent obviously these undesired side effects from immune therapy and it involves some immune
modulating supplements and so we certainly can send that to you as well but there are some things
to look out for with any therapy and immunotherapy immunotherapy is like any other there are some drawbacks
so just be careful with that okay so that brings us through all of the questions that came in
this week so now we'll get to the chat questions. Frankincense tested well for me is it useful to
perhaps put frankincense directly on my breast tumor I thought I'd use it I'd use the caster oil
as the carrier so yes if caster or if frankincense if a specific essential oil attested well
for you then absolutely you can use it in many different ways you can diffuse it you can apply it
toppically with the carrier oil so and some people take frankincense internally just by putting a
little drop on their thumb pressing it to the roof of their mouth so you can try that too but yes
absolutely you can put it topically on the tumor and just see how your body responds to that
all right oh you're very welcome what can help repair or support the kidneys so different
rife programs can help provide kidney support so I would do a search for kidneys in that search bar
that we just talked about and see if there's any kidney support programs which I know there are
so you can run those you can also take certain supplements we have kidney correct that's correct
spelled with a K so kidney correct is a great supplement for kidney support just making sure
you're staying hydrated and that your kidneys are you know you're able to flush things throughout
the system so those would be kind of main things that I would suggest to help with kidney support
how long can pulsing go it's it's working pretty well so far okay so this person is asking about
pulsing supplements which is another option so the question that I answered earlier about supplements
and you know kind of getting a little spendy on the supplements pulsing some of the supplements would
be an option as well so if you're taking a lot of supplements on top of the ones we've recommended a
lot of times our patients will pulse those so pulsing ultimately means you know if you have 10
different supplements maybe you break it down into you know five and five so you're going to take
only five of them for maybe a week or two and then you're going to rotate the other five in after
you're done taking the first five and so you're not taking all 10 at the same you know on a daily basis
you're still getting the nutrients from all 10 just on a rotating basis so you're not taking as many
on a daily basis and it can help save on the cost of supplements from a monthly basis so how long can
you do this you can really do it indefinitely you know if it's working for you you're not taking as
many because it's you know hard to take so many you can just continue with it and maybe there's a
few you know we can revisit it too with with testing we can see oh we really want to prioritize
these one or two so maybe take these on a daily basis the other ones we can pulse but if it's
working so far then I would stick with what you're doing and you know maybe the next time we're doing
a cheek swab we can test to see if we need to change anything up but I'm glad that it is working
and helping that's great how can I get my language language switched to English I have been having
some pain I think it might be good pain it feels like a strained muscle that you are massaging that
feels good if that makes sense but my lymph nodes under my arms are on fire but when I take a deep breath
I have this sensation okay I'm not really sure what you're referring to when you're talking about
how can I get my language switched to English is that on the computer I'm not really sure you'll have
to clarify that I'm sorry and then pain so you're thinking that it is good pain feels like a
strained muscle that you're massaging yes but lymph nodes under the arms are on fire but when I take
a deep breath I have this sensation so yeah so I'm not really sure you know I guess I would need a
little more information on the pain specifically did it just start recently you know could be because
you're recovering from the pneumonia and the COVID that could be playing a role your body is just
kind of clearing things out so maybe lymph nodes are a little more congested because your body is
working so hard to clear these other toxins out these other you know the viral load is higher
so that could be why so I agree that you know maybe it's not bad pain right now because your body is
dealing with recovering from these illnesses I'm sorry to hear that that pain is happening
but just keep working on you know detoxing and you know what you're doing some of these autophagy
things that we talked about can help clean out the cellular debris lymphatic massage all of those
things can be helpful all right is itching a sign of detoxing oh you're welcome is itching a
sign of detoxing my left arm at the wrist forearm and below the shoulder has intense itching throughout
the day no rash no bites any suggestions on relief ice is the best tool so far so yes itching can
be a sign of detoxing I would try running the program on the rife machine I believe it's called
itchy liver and I will verify that but I believe it's called itchy liver so if you type in the search bar
on the rife software itchy I'm pretty sure it will come up and it's itchy liver might be a
foot bath I can't remember but look for that but yes absolutely it can be a sign of detoxing
and so just you know work your way through that there are supplements you can take so it can be a
histamine response so we're you know detoxing so maybe we're we're freeing up some of these or we're
you know kind of dumping some toxic load into the body and so maybe your mast cells are having
hyper response because we're sending the immune system to the area and so a bunch of histamine is
being released by those mast cells so there are supplements you could take you could try taking
histamine scavenger you could try taking sun balance I would try sun balance first
that is a good one for a lot of itching or you know kind of the hyper histamine response so
I would also maybe try reducing your histamine burden as far as your diet and maybe that could help
and I don't know if there's anything that you might be sensitive to as far in the air or allergies
with you know if it's the change in the seasons and you're having if you normally have seasonal
allergies or something so you could be having just kind of this over spilling over of excess
histamines so you could try again lowering the histamines in your diet kind of maybe running some
right histamine programs on the right machine if there are any or allergy programs on the right
machine try that itching liver program try the sun balance product as well I think it's called
sun balance if it's not I'll look it up and send it to you I see the programs on the right that
use essential oils do we use those programs like you described earlier yes you can run those
essential oil programs and you can use the essential oil at the same time as running those
programs or if you don't have that specific essential oil it is really the frequency of the essential
oil that is being used in those rife programs so it's generating a similar response to using those
oils so yeah you could definitely try those essential oil programs it's the frequency of the
essential oil that is being run through those programs the zoom call is not in English
it's coming up as a different language my oh my email zoom is coming in a different language oh
there has got to be a way yes I would look at your zoom settings if you can figure that out I'm not
exactly sure where to point you because I don't really know where the zoom specific setting is but
go into your zoom account and look for a settings button and see if you can find a language
button and see if you can switch that because yeah that shouldn't be coming up in a different language
huh something must have gotten bumped all right so look for that oh you are so welcome any other
questions I think that is all of the chat questions that came in any other questions right and like I
mentioned if there's anything you know that you want me to send you whether it's a chemo protocol
or help with healthy weight gain or the name of something that I mentioned that you can't remember
just shoot me an email and I can get you that information I'll bring this screen up again because
I think some people jumped on a little bit later but we have a new store a phone number for the store
so this is the store phone number so if you have any questions about supplements or online ordering
products those types of things you can call that phone number now and then this is our shipping
email address so you can directly email them if you have a concern about your order I'll make a note
of that all right I think that is it for today everyone thank you for joining in on the call I hope
you all have a beautiful day and oh you're so welcome all right you guys take care bye bye